hélène boucher sur nos mails et nos
jeune femme moderne et avant-gardiste a
marqué tristement les yvelines en
s'écrasant avec son caudron rafale à
voisins le bretonneux
né en 1908 elle décédera à l'âge de 26
ans à aiguille en cours ellen bush est
une jeune fille tout à fait en jouer
par contre elle savait ce qu'elle
voulait faire puisque elle avait perdu
effectivement un grand ami de son frère
qui est décédé qui était aviateur pilote
d'essai qui était monsieur hubert et
elle a décidé au vu avec tout ça d'être
aviatrice dans son atelier camille tout
et a choisi de représenter et den
bossche enfants suite à une commande de
la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux la
sculpture trône à l'entrée de la commune
à la place de la piste de l'ancien
aérodrome que l'aviatrice utiliser ce
profil psychologique est assez
passionnant et ça m'a intéressé de de
l'encré dans sa petite enfance mais
c'est fictif convoyer déjà tout petit
c'est calais c'était une fille
déterminée
volontaire qui se cherchait un certain
temps allait passer par la culture par
les arts plastiques
une jeune femme décrit comme aventurière
aimant la vitesse et l'adrénaline avant
de devenir l'égérie de la marque caudron
renault elle utilisait la moto de son
frère et conduisait la voiture de son
père
chose rare pour l'époque elle boucher
elle se distingue peut-être de tout par
sa modernité
c'est vraiment aujourd'hui ça sera une
jeune fille d'aujourd'hui
en plus c'était une fille énergique jeu
toujours souriante et quant à l'arrivée
chez elle rue de rennes
on savait c'est elle on entendait sont
attaqués dans la cour et quand elle
montait l'escalier elle montait 4 à 4
c'était une fille qui était en mouvement
perpétuel
michel c'est niet n'a pas croisé le
chemin de les nommer les deux femmes
sont liés sur leurs formations aériennes
et sur leur combat féministe elle s'est
entraînée à la compétition avec un
moniteur qui s'appelle fred nicole ce
moniteur gelé bien connue parce que il
l'a entraînée en 32 pour les 12 heures
danger pour des compétitions comme ça et
ça a été mon moniteur de de voltige et
puis j'ai aussi très très bien connu
mars à bry par qui était l'ingénieur
découdront rafale qui lui a donné cette
souplesse si vous voulez
cet accompagnement cherono que j'ai
connu également hélène boucher devait
représenter son avion doté d'un moteur
renault lors d'une délégation japonaise
le 1er décembre au salon du bourget pour
effectuer un dernier vol d'essai elle
décolle pour la dernière fois de
l'aérodrome de guyancourt le 30 novembre
aux alentours de 15h30 de le ciel
n'était pas très beau mais elle a décidé
de le faire quand même
vers 16h30 elle a décidé de reposer son
avion son atterrissage s'est pas bien
passé elle a redécollé et on dernier
virage là où nous sommes aujourd'hui
elle a fait un demi tonneau pour essayer
de se reposer elle a perdu à priori d'un
peu de puissance elle a remis les gaz
insuffisant et elle s'est plantée à
landreau nous sommes ici elle décédera
dans l'ambulance sur le chemin de
l'hôpital à guyancourt alors accident à
cause de la météo erreur de pilotage ou
problème mécanique
le mystère reste entier elle manqué
d'entraînement sur l'avion c'est ce que
ce sont des avions qui étaient
difficiles et bas comme tous ces avions
qui sont difficiles c'est du
surentraînement surentraînement et là
c'est vraiment une faute de pilotage
hélène boucher sera enterré à
ermenonville près de la maison de son
enfance elle recevra la légion d'honneur
à titre posthume est un hommage national
aux invalides une première pour une
femme ou voisins le bretonneux nommera
en hommage à la jeune aviatrice sa rue
principale et son collège
[Musique]